[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلوها بادرس
العناوين
السيارات الاوكرانيه تهاجم قاعدتين جويتين
داخل الاراضي الروسيه وتوقع قتله
استجابه واسعه لنداء الاضرابات في ايران
والغرب يصف حال شرطه الاخلاق بالمراوغه
موسكو تستعجل للجمع بين اردوغان والاسد
وطهران تسعى لمنع اتمام المصالحه خوفا على
مصالحها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفي المونديال كرواتيا تقصي اليابان وتعبد
لدور الثمانيه وكوريا الجنوبيه تحمل اخر
الامال الاسيويه بلقاء البرازيل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا من الحرب في اوكرانيا
اذا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعتراض
وسائل الدفاع الجوي عددا من الطائرات
المسيره الاوكرانيه التي اطلقها نظام
اكياف ضد مطارين في مقاطعه ريازن وساراتوف
الروسيتين وقالت الدفاع الروسيه ان النظام
كيف حاول توجيه ضربات ضد مطار دياغلافو في
مقاطعه رزان ومطار انجلز في مقاطعه ساره
توب باستخدام طائرات مسيره سوفياتيه الصنع
[موسيقى]
هذا وافاد مراسل العربيه باستمرار القصف
الاوكراني على مدينه دنياس من ما خلف
قتيلا وجرحا حتى الان كما تم قصف المدينه
بصواريخ الجراد فيما تحدث مسؤول اوكرانيا
عن انفجارات في حركات جراء قصف روسي
بصواريخ كروز وقالت مصادر اوكرانيه ان
قصفان روسي مكثف على عده مناطق في البلاد
مشيره الى انقطاع الكهرباء والمياه في عده
مدن بسبب القصف الروسي هذا وقد طلبت
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه المواطنين بالنزول الى
الملاج بسبب القصف الروسي وافدت رويترز
بدرب صواريخ روسيه لمحطات طاقه فيسومي
شمالي شرقي اوكرانيا
تحدث وسائل الاعلام مولدوفيه عن سقوط
صاروخ روسيا داخل الاراضي المولدوفيه في
بلده على الحدود مع اوكرانيا وذلك بعد
ايام من اعلان حاله طوارئ في البلاد
وافادت وزاره الشؤون الداخليه في مولدوفا
ان شرطه الحدود اكتشفت صاروخا بالقرب من
بلده
بريشينياي واكلت الوزاره ذلك في بيان على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بان البنتاجون عدل عدل على صواريخ يمارس
المقدمه لاوكرانيا كي لا تصل الى مدى بعيد
ونقلت الصحيفه عن مسؤول امريكي قوله ان
واشنطن لا تريد ان تصل الصواريخ المقدمه
الكياف الى الاراضي الروسيه وانا
البنتاجون يقول انك قد تحصل على صواريخ
بعيده المدى عبر دور ثالثه
في الحرب الاوكرانيه ايضا وتيره القتال
بين الروس والاوكرانيين في الشرق تتباطا
احيانا في منطقه لتتشدد وتشتد في مناطق
اخرى تبدو اكثر اهميه بالنسبه للجانبين
وفي تفاصيل التطورات الميدانيه تشهد منطقه
سفات فوق الواقعه بين ليمان ولوجاست كما
نتابعنا صراعا كبيرا وصف بالدموي بين كل
من القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه مما دفع
الجيش الاوكراني الى حشد مزيد من
المقاتلين على هذه الجبهه كما تشاهدون هنا
تقدر بعشرات الالاف من اجل العوده
والسيطره على مدن كان قد خسرها في لوكا
تحديدا اما القوات الروسيه فتتقدم في
الشمال الروسي حيث منطقه دنياس التي تضم
باخمود افيتو ومارينكا التي سحب منها
الجيش الاوكراني تحت ضغط الضربات الروسيه
من المحور الشمالي مشاهدينا ننتقل الى
المحور الجنوبي في دونياسك القريبه من
ماريوبل حيث تشهد هذه المنطقه عمليات كروا
فرق بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه
وتحديدا حول مدينه اوجلدار التي تعتبر
استراتيجيه هنا ومهمه للجانبين وفق
مسؤولين عسكريين غربيين
[موسيقى]
معنى منك يا ابو مشاهدين ان يورساك مستشار
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني استاذ يونس ابدا من
الضربات الروسيه وعوده القصف الروسي على
المناطق الاوكرانيه من المعروف ان الروس
اليوم بحاجه
هل هذه الضربات يعني خلفت خسائر كبيره
واين تتركز
اسعد الله مساءكم اليوم
لدينا
اليوم اخر يوم الاثنين حافل بطلقات من
صواريخ التي طالت مدن الاوكرانيه وايضا
ضربت بنا تحتيه للطاقه بصوره عامه قام
الروسي اكثر من سبعه صواريخ اليوم والقوات
الدفاع الاوكرانيه استطاعت ان تسقط اكثر
70 صاروخا واسقطت قوات الدفاع الاوكرانيه
منها
جيد بالنسبه
المره الاخيره التي سوف تقوم فيها روسيا
بامطار تلك الصواريخ وسوف نعمل على تحسيني
انظمه الدفاعيه باستمرار وجع لي مدننا
اكثر امانه الضرر الذي تسببت به القوات
الروسيه كان قد لحق همم مناطق بسيطه من
الاهداف التي كانت تعتزم روسيا اصابتها
والضرر لم يكن كبيرا لكن هناك بعض البن
التحتيه الحيويه التي تعرضت للاصابات
وقوات الطوارئ
هناك عدد من القوات التي كانت تقاتل في
خرسان انتقلت اليوم الى الشرق الاكرانيا
هل الانتقال هذه القوات مع قوات التعبئه
التي بدات تصل الى الجبهه ممكن ان تغير
المعادله في الشرق الاكراني وستتقدم
القوات الروسيه هناك
علينا ان نتذكر
ان خطوط التماس تتسم بطبيعه دينميه
والقوات
هيئه القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه تقوم
باتخاذ القرارات بناءا على ما تشهده ساحه
المعركه ونحن مستمرون في عمليتنا الهجوميه
المضاده واذا ما قررت هيئه الاركان بان
بعض الاماكن في الخطوط الاماميه تتطلب الى
اعداد المزيد الى عدد اضافيه من القوات
فسوف تعمل على ارسالها اننا متاكدونا في
الفتره الحاليه بانه هناك قتال مستعر حول
مدينه بخمس وبكل تاكيد
الدفع بهذه القوات سوف يقضي الى صد رد
القوات الروسيه وروسيا في حقائق للامر
تخسر الالاف من جنودها في مساء
ولم تحقق اي شيء كما ذكرتهم في معرض
تقريركم بان الروس لم يستطيع ان يحققوا اي
نجاح عسكري ولهذا هم مستمرون في ترويع
الناس بطلقات الصواريخ اسمح لي ان اتطرق
الى موضوع التسريب الامريكي بان البنتاجون
عدل على صواريخ نيمار كي لا تصل الى
المناطق الروسيه وبانه يعول على ان تحصل
اكياس على صواريخ بعيده المدى من طرف ثالث
ما هو رد اوكرانيا على هذا الموضوع خصوصا
انكم طلبتم اكثر من مره بهذه الصواريخ ومن
هو الطرف الثالث
بالتعليق على صواريخه مارس او اجرائها
ايتها هناك لقد قلنا في اكثر من مناسبه
انه كل ما زادت فعاليه
القواتنا اذا ما حصلنا على صواريخ التي
لديها قوه قوه الناريه بمدى طويل وهذا
يسهل علينا استهداف العدو ولكن للاسف هذه
قد تكون محظو اشاعات ولا استطيع ان اقدم
لك اي تعليقات ذات مغزى
يا استاذ يوري ساك مستشار وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني حدثتنا من كاس
زار الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين جسر
القرم الذي دمر جزءيا في اكتوبر في اول
زياره له الى شبه الجزيره التي ضمتها
موسكو عام 2014 منذ بدء الهجوم على
اوكرانيا وظهر بوتين يقود سياره على الجسر
الذي يربط بين شبه جزيره القرم الاوكرانيه
والاراضي الروسيه وتضرر الجسر في اكتوبر
لشراء انفجار قوي نسبته السلطات الروسيه
الى القوات الاوكرانيه
تدمير المكتبات ومحو الارث الثقافي
لاوكرانيا كان الجزء الرئيسي من
استراتيجيه روسيا عندما بدات عمليتها
العسكريه في اوكرانيا من اجل القضاء على
الهويه الاوكرانيه والقضاء على اي انتماء
وطني للاوكرانيين وفقه ما كشفت صحيفه
الجارديان البريطانيه تدور معظم الحروب
حول من سيحدد المستقبل والحرب الاوكرانيه
هي صراع حول من سيحدد الماضي تقول ايضا
الصحيفه البريطانيه التي كشفت ان قبل
ثلاثه ايام من اندلاع الحرف اوكرانيا قدم
الرئيس الروسي بلادي مير بوتن ما يرقى الى
مستوى اطروحه تاريخيه كاعلام حرب وكانت
حجته انا اوكرانيا كانت خيالا خلقته روسيا
بالكامل من دون التقاليد المستقره للدوله
الحقيقيه ولكن الرئيس الاوكراني فولو دي
ميرسي رد عليه بان الهويه الاوكرانيه
موجوده وهي ذات طبيعه اوروبيه ومنذ بدايه
حرب استهدفت روسيا المكتبات الاوكرانيه
وابرزها ارشيف الدوله في تشارياف الذي
يحتوي على معلومات حساسه حول قمع الحقد
سوفياتيه التي اراد الروس محوها من السجل
التاريخي
[موسيقى]
مع بدء سريان الحظر الاوروبي على الخانه
الروسيه رفضت روسيا بايع النفط للبلدان
التي تشارك في فرد سقف الاسعار مؤكده انها
لن تصدر الخام الخاضع لسقف سعريه او لسقف
سعري فرضه الغرب حتى لو اضطرت لخفض
انتاجها هذا واكد الرئاسه الروسيه ان
تحديد سقف لسعر النفط الروسي من جانب
الدول الغربيه لن يكون له تداعيات على
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا وحذرت من
زعزعه استقرار سوق الطاقه العالميه وهو
وسط هذا المشهد قفزت اسعار النفط اثنين
بالمئه بعد ما ابقى الدول تحالف كلاس على
اهدافها المتعلقه بالانتاج قبل حضر
الاتحاد الاوروبي للخام الروسي ووضعي سقف
له
[موسيقى]
تحديد المحتاجين بالقتل والتوعد
بالاعدامات امر لم يعد يعيب النظام
الايراني
في البلاد منذ اكثر من شهرين ونصف النظام
الايراني تعرض لخيبه امل كبيره اذ توقع ان
تخفف قرارات امس بحل شرطه الاخلاق ودراسه
الزاميه الحجاب من غضب المحتاجين لكن
النتيجه كانت عكسيه فالمحتاجون اعتبروا
هذه الخطوات مراوغه وانها لن تغير في
سياسه النظام شيئا بل انه مجرد تغيير في
التكتيك مشددين اي نشطاء الايرانيين على
ان سقف طموحاتهم وما طالبهم هي اكبر من
شرطه الاخلاق الا وهي تغيير النظام الحالي
وهنا جنا جنون الحارس الثوري الذي ارسل
رسالته متواعدا المحتاجين بانه لن يرحمهم
ابدا لكن تلك حتى ذلك تهديد عاد ايجابيا
على الاضطرابات التي امتدت لمناطق كبيره
داخل الجغرافيا الايرانيه وهذه صور
مشاهدينا مباشره لمظاهرات ليليه في حي
نرماك بطهران بايران فن تبعها
[موسيقى]
اذا المشاهدين هذه كانت صور وفيديوهات
لمظاهرات ليليه خرجت ب طهران بموازاه
الاضراب العام الذي دعا له الشعب الايراني
منذ بدء هذا اليوم
مروز سعوديه
[موسيقى]
حول قرار حل شرطه الاخلاق في ايران قللت
كل من واشنطن وبرلين من اهميه وقيمه هذا
القرار اذا علقت امريكا على القرار
القائله ان ذلك لم يغير شيئا من وضع
النساء في ايران والحريات هناك فيما
اعتبرته برلين قرارا غير كافيا و ملبيا
للطموح حيث اكدت الخارجيه الالمانيه ان
الايرانيين والايرانيات ينزلون الى الشارع
للدفاع عن حقوقهن الاساسيه لا يريدون
العيش بحريه واستقلاليه وهذا الاجراء في
حاله تطبيق لن يغير هذا الامر اطلاق
اذا الاطاحه بشرطه الاخلاق واعاده النظر
بمواد الدستور الايراني لم يطح بعزيمه
المحتاجين على استكمال انتفاضاتهم لاسقاط
النظام المحتجون دعوا الى اضراب عام في
كافه انحاء البلاد بدءا من اليوم وستستمر
الى بعد غد الاضرابات شملت معظم المدن
الايرانيه كما نشاهد على هذه الخريطه
وابرزها طهران اصفهان كارمن شاه قزوين
وكردستان وغيرها طبعا من المدن الايرانيه
فالمحلات التجاريه في سوق نقش جهان
التاريخي الذي تاسس قبل 500 عام في اصفهان
تم اغلاقها بالكامل كما سنشاهد بهذه الصور
[موسيقى]
تصبحون
على فكره
سببها سلار وهو اكبر اسواق العاصمه في
مشاهدت مدينه كرمان جنوب شرق البلاد
اضرابا عاما نتابع ايضا المشاهد منه هناك
[موسيقى]
ساره ساره
عبد الله في طهران ايضا ودوا صدى الصوت
الرجاء المحطه فلنستمع اليها
[موسيقى]
من باريس ينضم الينا المشاهدين
هل يمكن القول اليوم وسطى ازمه النظام
بانها بريسترويك طهران فاما التصلب يعني
حتى هدر الدماء واما اكمل الاصلاحات حتى
انهيار النظام
الله معك
الى حقيقيه لكن حقيقه الامر ان تلك
المظاهرات كانت تحدث في كافه ارجاء البلاد
في وقت متزامن
وفتره طويله
ولكن الفارق بين هذه التظاهرات مع تلك
التي انطلقت في الماضي
باسقاط النظام والمرشد الاعلى
نشوف
فاكتاني الحقيقتان لو هما جديدتان كليا
لدى فان النظام في ايران يستخدموا
قواته من الشرطه لاحتواء تلك الحركه ولا
يوجد لديهم اي همم قوه لصد المتظاهرين
الذين يقفون ضد النظام
لم يشهده في السابق على هذا المستوى
اليوم يعني الدبلوماسيين الاوروبيين
يعتبرون بان النظام وصل الى نقطه الا عوده
وبانه يدور في حلقه مفرغه بعدما فقد احد
اهم عناصر الثوره وهي التواصل مع الشعب
وان يكون الحكم هو امتداد للشعب ما يعني
ماذا يعني ذلك على مستقبلا النظام
غير موجود بصوره نسبيه اي بمعنى اخر ان
النظام
لا يمتلك اي دوله في اوروبا تسانده
فالدعم ياتي بصوره عامه من الصين
او روسيا في الظل ظروف محدده وكل دوله
تقوم بدعم النظام الايراني تفعل هذا الامر
لاسبابها الخاصه وليس
حبا
هذا النوع من تلك الانظمه هو هذا قد يشمل
سوريا وفنزويلا وغيرهم لكن
هذا الامر لا يحمل اي روابط ايديولوجيه مع
اي طرفين دعم
ان هذا الدعم الذي قد يحصل عليه النظام
الايراني قد لا يكون كافيا
لكن
نسبه العداء التي ظهرت بين اوساطي الدوائر
الدبلوماسيه الغربيه كبيره للغايه
والعاليه اقول ان الراي العام في في
اوروبا وخاصه في فرنسا
هو
يقف بجانب المتظاهرين في الشارع مشكلتهم
وهنا اننا انخرطنا في الوضع في اوكرانيا
في ذات الوقت وحتى الى حد اقل في الماضي
الارمنيه لذا هناك الكثير من الامور التي
يمكن للشعب الفرنسي ان ان يستعبوه من وجهه
نظر هذا بالاضافه الى كاس العالم الى كره
كاس العالم
يعني استكمانا لما قلته عن موضوع العزله
الخارجيه والعزله الداخليه للنظام هناك
نقاش حقيقي في الداخل ماذا كان سيسعى
النظام الى كسر هذه العزله عبر تحالف
متنامي اكثر مع روسيا وحلفاء ام الذهاب
جديه لاحياء الاتفاق النووي هل ممكن يعني
احياء الاتفاق النووي بظل هذه الظروف التي
تحيط النظام
فعل ذلك من عظمه لا اعلم
لكن ما هي النتائج التي قد تحملها هذه
الامور على بعض العواصم مثل باريس وهو
واشنطن فانني
اشك بان ثمه ردي فعلا ايجابيه قد تظهر اذا
ما اعيدت خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه على
مسارها لان فرنسا ترغب بحدوث ذلك فليس
كافيا ان نقوم فقط بدفع النظام
من خلال الضغوط الدبلوماسيه بما يفضي
للاطاحه به فهذا لا قد لا يفلح رغم انه قد
ينجح في بعض الاحيان
وهناك المشكله النوويه
مشكله عدم دفع النظام والضغط عليه
لاستخدام الكرت النووي ليكون فزاعه للجميع
وترهيب مواطنيه لدى فان خطه العمل الشامله
المشاركه قد تلقى اذان صاغيه وهذاني امران
مختلفان من قبل الدبلوماسيين فمساله
الحديثه عن حقوق الانسان او السلاح
النوويه وفي المرحله الحاليه لا يوجد اي
اشاره للخلطين هذين
استاذ هارون هيمان الكاتب السياسي حدثنا
من باريس
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بسبب تويتر ثروه له ماسك في تراجع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد افادت مراسله العربيه
باغلاق الشرطه الالمانيه لاسواق الميلاد
في مدينه داسل دور بسبب تهديد الامن غير
معروف حتى اللحظه وبحسب صحيفه المانيه
هناك شخص اتصل وهدد بقياده شاحنه داخل سوق
الميلاد بالقرب من مقر بلديه مدينه داسل
جروف واشارت الصحيفه الى ان اخلاء السوق
وانتشار القوات الخاصه هو اجراء احترازي
[موسيقى]
الى الملف السوري وتحديدا الحديث حول
اعاده التطبيع بين تركيا ونظام الاسد اذا
حددت انقره شروطها للقاء الرئيس التركي
اردوغان وبشر الاسد في حال ازال الاخير
مخاوف انقر الامنيه وضمن امن الحدود
التركيه السوريه عبر تخليها عن دعم قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه التي يشكل اكراد عمودها
الفقري طبعا هذا وفقا المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه التركيه ابراهيم كالين الذي جدد
المساعد تركيا نحو لقاء اردوغان والاسد
شريطه تصرف دمشق بمسؤوليه تجاه جارتها
انقره حسب الوصف التركي طبعا هذا من
الجانب التركي اما الوسيطه فهي تحاول وما
تزعل الى عقد مصالحه بين كل من انقره
والاسد الا ان الرفض الايراني يعرق
الاتمام هذه المصالحه لانها قد تتمع على
حساب مصالح طهران في سوريا وفقا ما افاد
به مصدر ديبلوماسي روسي العربيه دوت نت
[موسيقى]
بعد سنوات من العداء المرير الذي تجاوز
عقدا من الزمن تحرك روسي يهدف لعقد لقاء
بين الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ورئيس
النظام السوري بشار الاسد
مصادر دبلوماسيه افادت بان موسكو تخطط
لعقد لقاء مصالحه بين الجانبين تفاديا
لعمليه عسكريه في سوريا لان موسكو مشغوله
في حرب كبيره في اوكرانيا المصادر نفسها
تؤكد ان مساعي روسيا لترتيب اللقاء تنطلق
من يقينها من خطوره العمليه العسكريه
باعتبارها مصدر تهديد خطير للاستقرار
الاقليمي وحتى الدولي المصادر المحت الى
دور ايراني خفي يدفع الاسد لمقاومه ضغط
موسكو فطيره ان تخشى من نجاح روسيا بخلق
وفاق بين الاسد واردوغان ينعكس سلبا على
مصالحها في سوريا
محللون اشاره الى ان طهران تدرك مخاطر
القيام بهذه العمليه على نفوذها كماليا
العراق وسوريا ما دفعها للدخول بتفهمات
عسكريه واضحه مع حزب العمال الكردستاني
وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه لتامين الوصول
الى المتوسط العلاقات بين اردوغان والاسد
تازمت منذ دلاع الصراع في سوريا في عام
2011 انذاك اعلنت انقره دعمها مقاتلي
المعارضه في حين رد النظام السوري اتهام
تركيا بدعم الارهاب فضلا انت وغولات
عسكريه متكرره في شمالي سوريا
بلال البشداني العربيه
من الحسكه ينضم الينا صالح مسلم الرئيس
المشترك لحزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي استاذ
صالح يعني استكمالا لما سمعناه هناك ايضا
تسريب سوريا يقول بان الاسد لا يريد ان
يعطي هديه مجانيه لاردوغان قبل الانتخابات
خصوصا ان الموضوع الاساسي اليوم هو اعاده
اللاجئين وهو موضوع على العمليه العسكريه
الشمالي سوريا ماذا تتوقع من هذا التقارب
قبل كل شيء نود ان نشير بان اليد العليا
في سوريا في القضيه السوريه
والازمه السوريه هي الان هي دروسها وروسيا
تتطلب مصالح وهذه ان يكون هناك ثقافه بين
النظام السوري وهمم وارضوان على موضوع
واحد وهو محاربه الكره او ليست فقط وانما
الاداره ذاتيه الديمقراطيه التي تجمع بين
القرد والعربي والسريان والتركمان يعني
الشعوب الموجوده في شمال سوريا هذا
المشروع لا يستجيب الجميع وخاصه ان هذا
المشروع باء يعني همم ياخذ المكان او في
معادلات الشرق الاوسط وله
ربما روسيا التي تطلب من ارضه بان يتراجع
اما اطلقه سابقا من شعارات همم اتصالات
اموي وما الى ذلك وسمى همم تطلب من من
الاسد من الاستقبال هذا ربما هي تتجاهل
جميع ال- ال- يعني
العوامل الاخرى مثل احتلال تركيا لمناطق
شاسعه من الارض السوريه وتسبب تركيا في
ازمات سوريا كلها هي منذ البدايه موجوده
فيها ولهذا اعتقد ان النظام السوري لا
يستطيع القفز سوف كل ما حدث
ويتوحد مع تركيا في سبيل المحاربه الجزء
من شعبه من الشعب السوري الذي دافع عن
سياده سوريا واشعب سوريا والكرامه سوريا
مصلحه مشتركه تركيا سوريا وبالتالي هل
ممكن ان يعني تسرع المصالح اكثر وهل
الشروط التركيه بشمالي سوريا قابله
للتحقيق همم شرط ايقاف العمليه او ان تكون
محدوده من الجانب الكردي طبعا
الدوله السوريه او من النظام السوري ان
يكون بمحاربه قسم من
شعبي من شعبه الذي دافع عن كرامه سوريا
وهو موجود يعني على الارض وله مشروع
تريد يعني بالاضافه الى حربها مع
المتطرفين الذين موجودين
في حضن تركيا وفي المناطق الاحتلال التركي
انا جامعه هؤلاء الجهاديين
الارهابيين بما في بقايا داعش والنصره
والشام يعني كيف تخفي سوريا من فوق كل ذلك
وتقوم بمحاربه
شمال سوريا التي استطاع تحرير اراضيها من
داعش يعني هذا ربما لا يخطر على البال
بالاضافه الى ان تركيا هي سبب الازمه هي
السبب الازمه السوريه كلها يعني الان
الاداره ذاتيه الديمقراطيه لا زالطالب
بالحفاظ على وحده الارض السوريه وعلى وحده
الشعب السوري وتبحث عن الحل السياسي ولكن
كل ما يعرقل ذلك تركيا وفي ليله بين ليله
وضحاها تتحول الى همم محاوله كسب النظام
السوري الذي
لمحاربه الكره
الارضيه الكردي منذ بدايه هذه الازمه على
الموقف الامريكي الذي كانت داعا لهذا
الكيان اليوم هناك مصلحه روسيه بان يكون
هناك تقارب تركي سوري ولو على حساب حساب
الاكراد هل تعولون على الموقف الامريكي
لا يعني لابد ان نشير الى الى اسبانيا
يعني محاربه الاداره الذاتيه الديمقراطيه
ومحاربه التحالف الدولي هو كان بقرار من
الاسيتانه التي رقم 19
في الدوري موجود هنا لمحاربه داعش وداعش
الان لا زال تستمد قوتها من تركيا تركيا
هم الذين يمولونها وهم الذين يحدثون بها
وهم الذين يدربون في مناطق الاحتلال لا
زال داعش موجوده
ولذلك نحن نعتقد من جانبنا اذا كان فعلا
احدهم يريد ان يحارب داعش فعليه ان يقطع
من يساند داعش يعني موارد عاش
المناطق التي تستمد منها داعش قوتها
الماديه والاسلحه التي ولهذا
تركيا هي الدعم الاساسي لهذا التركيه
هدفها خلق داعش من جديد بالنسبه الى
امريكا طبعا لا زال هناك حرب يجر يتم شنهو
على داعش على شكل الخلايا ومن ذلك محاولات
للافراج عن السجون والمعسكرات تركيا
تقول بان هذا الاعتداء سيعر مساعينا في
محاربه» هذا هو الذي تتمسك بها امريكا
ونحن لم نطلب من امريكا عن تحمينا ولا ولا
باختصار انتم اليوم كاكراد وكهيئات كرديه
هل لديكم اينيه او اي مصلحه يعني بالحوار
مع الاتراك هل هناك
نيه باختصار لو سمحت
نحن جزء من سوريا ما دام هناك مناطق محتله
في سوريا وما الى ذلك بدون وعود رصيدنا
وبدون وسيط بان يضمن الخروج التركي من هذه
المناطق المحتله من سوريا لا يمكن ولكل
شيء حديث طبعا
للحوار مع جميع الاطراف
مسلم الرئيس
[موسيقى]
شو اخبار الرياضه والمونديال مشاهدينا نجح
المنتخب الكرواتي في الصعود الى ربع نهائي
كاس العالم بعد الفوز على اليابان بركلات
الترجيح عقب انتهاء الوقتين الاصلي
والاضافي بالتعادل بهدف لكل جانب وبذلك
يبقى منتخب كوريا الجنوبيه المنتخب
الاسيوي الوحيد في المونديال ويلتقي
المنتخب الكوري بعد قليل مع البرازيل
التفاصيل مع الزميل لاسباساري
ليس يعني اليك مباشره كيف هي اجواء هذه
المباراه قبل انطلاقها
اجواء مولعه
في الدوحه الكثير من القمصان الصفر
والاخضر اللون المنتخب البرازيلي وهناك من
اتى على متن طائرات وحافلات من مناطق
مختلفه ليس فقط من قطر من جميع انحاء
العالم وخصوصا البرازيل عند الانسان
كره القدم البرازيلي الشهيره
ريكارديو صعب اللفظ البرتغالي ولكن وانا
بحكي معكم راح تشوفوا حركات بعملها اجى
يعملها مقابل
المكان الذي ستقام فيه المباراه بين كوريا
الجنوبيه وبين البرازيل راموس
هذا ما يحدث هنا في الدوحه الكثير من
المشجعين ياتون ويقدمون عروض ولكن ما اجمل
ان يقدم عرض فوتبول اثناء كاس العالم هناك
في الدوحه واثناء لاعب منتخب بلده هذا
الشخص البرازيل لذلك لذلك هناك كثير من
ال- من النشاطات وهناك الكثير من يعني رح
نكون اللايف كله مباشر كامل مش راح يوقف
الكره انا متاكد لانه راح حتى هذا هذا
اللاعب هو لاعب سابق في البرازيل وهو يقوم
بهذه الحركات وهناك الكثير الكثير من
البرازيليين الذين يصيدون الان المباراه
ستقام بعد اقل من 20 دقيقه من الان وهم ما
زالوا يصلون وهناك حسود وحسود يعني بتوقع
على ليالي يمكن لازم يربح كاس العالم لانه
بعدني بحكي وهو بعد ههه
[ضحك]
نعم هناك عائلات اخرى ساحاول اثناء ما هو
يقوم بهذه الحركات الرياضيه او الفوتبول
حركات كره القدم ساقوم باستضافه من الذين
اتوا من البرازيل الكثير من الذين وصلوا
منذ منذ منذ ساعات هنا الى استاد
برازيليانو
برازيليا
[موسيقى]
من الناس
الفرق التي ستلعب بعد قليل ااه شكرا لك
ليس بازاري من فضل العربيه
[موسيقى]
الى السودان وفي تصريحات للعربيه قال رئيس
مجلس سياده السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان
ان الاتفاق الايطالي الذي تم توقيعه لم
يتجاوز احدا مشيرا الى ان الجميع في
السودان يسعى لحدوث توافق داخل مختلفه
القوى السياسيه والعسكريه
اساسي يشارك في نقاش ما طلع فيه من قضايا
نحن نسعى لحدوث توافق اذا كان داخل القوى
السياسيه او داخل القول سياسيه والعسكريه
همم
لكمال هذا توافق بين هذه المجموعات ونزع
الاستكمال توقيع القوه التي نرى انها
ضروريه ان تكون موجوده في ساحه السياسيه
رحبت الخارجيه السعوديه بتوقيع الاطراف
السياسيه السودانيه لاتفاق الايطالي
للانتقال السياسي في البلاد واكدت
الخارجيه السعوديه انها ستواصل دعم
السودان لحفظ امنه واستقراره ولما من شانه
تحقيق السلام والنماء وجدد الدعم المملكه
الاليه الثلاثيه في تسهيل الحوار
والمباحثات بين اطراف المرحله الانتقاليه
واشنطن بدورها رحبت بالاتفاق الايطالي
للانتقال السياسي في السودان وقالت ان
تشكيل الحكومه مدنيه في البلاد عام
الاساسيه للاستئناف المساعدات الدوليه
واكلت واشنطن انها تنسق مع الشركاء لتقديم
بدعم الاقتصادي كبير للحكومه المدنيه
الانتقاليه في السودان
هذا وكانت القوى السياسيه السودانيه قد
وقعت على الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يهدف الى
حل الجمود السياسي في البلاد
وحظر التوقيع حضر التوقيع ممثلون عن
الاتحادين الافريقي والاوروبي والامم
المتحده والاليه الثلاثيه واللجنه
الرباعيه ونصه بنود الاتفاق الايطاليه على
تنظيم انتخابات في نهايه الفتره
الانتقاليه المحدده بعامين والتي تبدا منذ
لحظه تعيين رئيس الوزراء كما اشارت ابرز
البنود الى الاتفاق على شخصيه مدنيه شرفيه
لرئاسه الدوله ونصف الاتفاق الايطالي
السودانيه على التاكيد على جيش وطني موحد
ومهني وان يكون رئيس الدوله هو القائد
العام للجيش
[موسيقى]
لعنه التويتر تلحقوا ثروت الى مصر
تظهر انها غارقه بالخسائر
لموقع اكسيوس الامريكي الذي احصى خسائر
كبيره للملياردير المثير للجدل خلال عام
2022 تظهر انه كان عامل خساره بامتياز
الموقع اشار الى ان الامر بالغ الاهميه
نظرا الى ان ماسك يعد ايقونه النجاح
التكنولوجي في العالم وبات اغنى رجل على
الكوكب بثروه تقدر وتقترب من 200 مليار
دولار لكن صفقاته الماليه هذا العام وعلى
راسها شراء تويتر قللت من مدخيل ماسك
والحقت الاضرار براس ماله رغم ان ثروه
ماسك تعد بمئات المليارات الى ان المشكله
الاساسيه فيها تكمن في ان نسبه كبيره منها
مرتبطه مباشره باسهم شركه تسلا للسيارات
الكهربائيه والتي تراجعت بنسبه تصل الى
50% في هذا العام
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى اخبار التاسعه مع زياده اقبال
المصريين على شراء الذهب حفاظا على قيمه
العمله المصريه الاخذ في التدهور شحات
السباك السبائك وجنيهات الذهبيه من السوق
فهم يفضلون شرائها على المشغولات الذهبيه
هذا الامر قفز بسعر الذهب الى مستويات
تاريخيه غير مسبوقه وفي نفس الوقت يشعر
القطاع بالقلق على مستقبل الصناعه
والصناعه الصناعه المهره لانها هذه ولان
هذه الارتفاعات خلقت ركودا في سوق
المشغولات وبالتالي تهدد بعض الورش
والمصانع بالتوقف
بعكس ما يحسبه الكثيرون يشكل ارتفاع سعر
الذهب خبرا غير سعيدا للقطاع ككل فبالنسبه
لرفعت صبري صاحب متجر المصوغات ينعكس هذا
ليس فقط على قله المبيعات ولكن على قله
ربحيته هو الاخر كتاجر
بس عشان الاسعار العاليه دي فبتحاول
تشتريه على اساس ان قيمه الجنيه بتقل
فيقول لك يعني ممكن اشتريها خليها في
الدهب افضل
القيمه في اوقات التضخم من عكس على رؤيتهم
لشراء الذهب او غيره من الاصول في حاله ان
انا استثمر سبايكه جنيهات لا اقتنع عقارات
ذهب
لان العقار بيزيد اعلى من الذهب لقدام
عمره الذهب
في السوق المحليه تزامنه مع تراجع سعر
الجنيه امام الدولار الامر الذي زاد من
الطلب عليه كمخزون للقيبه او زينه وخزينه
كما يحب ايهاب واصف ان يطلق على هذا
المعدن النفيس لكنه في الوقت نفسه يشعر
بالقلق على مستقبل العماله الحرفيه
الماهره في مصر في تاثير على عدد العماله
كبيره وفيه هروب كان همم في 2011 للعماله
ال- ال- الحنفيه كبير كانوا بيهربوا من
القطاع لعدم احساسهم بالامان والاستقرار
في القطاع بس النهارده احنا عندنا الامان
والاستقرار ولكن عندنا ارتفاعات الاسعار
وهذا فتح الحديث عن التركيز في التصدير
للحفاظ على العماله المدربه والماهره وهو
ما جعل شعبه الذهب تطالب الحكومه بالغاء
رسم التسمين الذي يبلغ نصف في المئه من
قيمه المشغولات فهل تشكل هذه النسبه
البسيطه تفارقا الى هذا الحد هو يفرم معنا
كثير طبعا لانه هو هيخرجني بره حيز
المنافسه من بعض الدول وبعدين احنا
المنافسه النهارده قويه جدا النصف% بيشكل
عائق كبير علينا ان احنا نظهر كلاس ان في
بعض الدول بتدي دعم على الصادرات احنا مصر
ما بتتعملش مع الذهب بدعم ابدا تتوقف
تسعيره الذهب في السوق المصريه نظرا لعدم
وجود معروض من السبائك التي يسعى الجميع
الان لشرائها وان استمر بيعه المشغولات
على اسعار لم يصل اليها جرام الذهب في مصر
من قبل تامر ناصر العربيه القاهره
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
وسيارات الاوكرانيه تهاجم قاعدتين جويتين
داخل الاراضي الروسيه وتوقع قتله
استجابه واسعه لنداء الاضرابات في ايران
والغرب يصف حال شرطه الاخلاق بالمراوغه
موسكو تستعجل للجمع بين اردوغان والاسد
وطهران تسعى لمنع اتمام المصالحه خوفا على
مصالحها
[تصفيق]
وفي المونديال كرواتيا تقسي اليابان وتعبد
لدور الثمانيه وكوريا الجنوبيه تحمل اخر
الامال الاسيويه بلقاء البرازيل
[تصفيق]
التاسعه انتهت مشاهدينا لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله الان الى 360 مع
الزميله راويه راويه ماذا لديك الليله
اهلا بك ليال سنتحدث عن توقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي في السودان وايضا عن تحركات
مكروه الدبلوماسيه للجلوس على الطاوله
الحوار في ما يخص الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا